[Music]
my name is Austin I'm going to be
talking about actionable and credible
predictions from a stack model in
particular how to think about building a
model based on business requirements so
to give some context I work at halo
technologies and Hill attacks is
accelerating adoption of medical
advancements with evidence-based
insights so the medical and biotech
industries are incredibly important in
the u.s. they represent a large
percentage of GDP and generally good
health the way that we think that we can
do this best is the acceleration is by
working with biotech and manufacturers
so you can think of these as being ene
sequencers or other types of clinical
and biotech manufacturing one of the
reasons for this is because there you
spend twenty to thirty percent of their
revenue just on cell D so that's in
sales and marketing that's a huge
fraction of their income and of their of
these expenditures that they make so if
we can reduce this then we can reduce
the costs of providing healthcare all
the way downstream and we can also make
this plunge faster so if we are able to
identify here are the people that a
sales team should actually to to try to
sell something then we can make sure
that this new technologies that are
being developed are actually being
directed to the right people
so in particular the way that we do this
is by building data products so we
collect data from a variety of sources
do some aggregations and market
landscape analysis and then integrate
this with our clients data to make them
more successful
in particular we've had data from a
variety of different sources so we have
a data ingestion platform so that we can
get data from SEC filings publications
clinical trials various types of prints
and a slew of other sources each of
these are either unstructured or semi
structured a few of them actually do
have some structure to them so we've
spent a lot of time actually getting
this into a system so that we can put
everything into a useful structured
format for our own purposes a large part
of that is involving entity resolution
unfortunately we have relatively weak
signals as our keys so instead of having
something like an email address or a
phone number we have to rely on first
name last name institution you're in
many cases for example in a publication
we have the authors of that publication
won't have any information about what
their email differences but we still
need to be able to identify that Sally
Smith at Stanford is the same person as
Sally Smith at Stanford University
biology department in some specific year
in addition to that since we're getting
data from a variety of sources like
publications and clinical trials we need
to be able to identify that this person
who's publishing in an academic journal
is the same person that's running this
clinical trial the reason for this is
because we need this entire market
landscape of anyone who would purchased
from a biotech or med tech manufacturer
this is a small enough total population
in the US that we aim to actually have a
complete coverage and then when we have
client data that we join into this we
are able to have their customer list as
a subset of a set of data that we have
once we have our entity solution we
figured out who actually is the
contributors to these various types of
data we need to do some refinements on
that so this involves text analysis
feature
and a bunch of other types of downstream
data and aggregation collection or
cleaning from the raw data that we got
from either from the data investor so a
lot of the text analysis for example
will be trying to figure out is this
particular abstract relevant to this
line of flight profits and in addition
to that we will need to make sure it's
not relevant for the wrong reasons for
example biostatisticians are probably
not actually going to be purchasing in
DNA sequencer but we do need to know if
someone is a biostatistician
so that we can rule them in as a
potential customer so they might come a
lot of the same types of words in their
abstract because they want to do similar
work they're just taking a different
sort of approach so that's sort of the
data refinement is cleaning up the data
that we already have and this puts us
this gets data available for us or
various types of models we have
predictive and exploratory models for
the users are our salespeople at our
client companies in this talk I'm going
to focus on an example of how to start
with a with business requirements around
a predictive model and then how to build
a simple model that actually achieves
those goals
so in in one example a sales person
needs to be able to achieve all three of
these goals understanding each leads
work in the context of the client
company so that means that if we're
looking at the academic segment we need
to know that some researcher is actually
relevant to what our clients selling in
addition that if we have someone from a
biotech startup that does some genome
analysis for example then we need
be able to know what type of work
they're doing so that we can tell the
salespeople what types of products would
actually be relevant to them and after
we're able to understand each please
work in the context of our clients we
need to be able to find which are
actually a high-value leads which people
are going to spend money and our clients
and then once we have that the
salespeople need to actually take some
actions with these leads meaning that
there are different types of benefits
that they can offer such as some a
discount or spending more time for this
particular customer so that could be
looking at the amount of phone calls or
meetings in the past six months so we're
going to start with those three
requirements and we have several sources
of data that we can work with to try to
build a model that actually addresses
these three goals for example we if we
want to look at just the total amount of
spend or that finding the high value
these we can start with customers and
data so this might be how much money did
each customer spend on each product over
the past year at this clients so that
might be the response variable that we
were going to start with and that's
provided from a client in addition we
have our full market landscape which is
built from the data that I spoke about
earlier coming in from this data
ingestion and that we later clean up so
this is going to be a superset of a
number of this 2% of the entities that
will purchase from the client so the
customer some of the customers and will
have will not match in here because
it'll it will just that lead would not
actually spend any money at the clients
company so a third piece of data that we
have is salesperson actions so this is
what actions did the salesperson take
when that particularly over the past
some unit of time
so this again could be something like
did they offer a discount so these three
sources of data that customers spend is
our response information every response
feature the full market landscape is the
data that halo kept has that is our
market landscape so this and this is
data that describes the customers
leashes X trend which is just
characteristics of those customers and
we have salesperson actions which are
interactions between the salesperson and
the customer so in order to try to get
at this first goal of understanding each
leads work in the context of the
salesperson company we can build a first
layer of models just connecting the
customer spend with the full market
landscape so that's training a model
where the response variable is the
customer spend and the explanatory
features are a full market landscape
data so from here we can build an
opportunity table and we can then
actually achieve this goal of having
figuring out what the leads work is in
the context of the client company by
looking at for example the local
importances in this opportunity model so
if we just have a random forest or that
opportunity model then there are
standard methods like global importances
so that you can figure out what are the
relevant features on a curb prediction
basis in that block so that it allows us
to achieve this first goal from there we
can take the output from that
opportunity model and take the negative
residuals so that is the predicted minus
the observed values because that
represents an opportunity that the
salesperson can actually go out go out
after because if we think that this
particularly has an opportunity to spend
million dollars with the client but
there are actually only
a hundred thousand then that represents
a two hundred thousand dollar difference
that we would expect to be available
that this customers characteristics like
how much money they have raised in grant
funding or the types the type of
research that they have published on
various other features suggests that
there is a more opportunity than is
actually being achieved by the
salespeople at this time so we can take
that negative residual from the
opportunity model and build another
layer of model using that as the
response variable and using the
salesperson actions as the explanatory
features so when we do that we get some
predictions of what which are actually
the values that salespeople can get by
going after these individual leads
because we're predicting we don't want
to just predict that difference in
predicted minus observed in the
opportunity model we also need to know
that that is explainable by salesperson
actions so if if we have a high
prediction a high predictive value in
that action model then we expect that
there are actions that a salesperson can
take that will actually lead to a higher
amount of spend and using the same trick
as before in the opportunity model we
can look at if we decide to make this
another brand importance because that
has nice properties of explained ability
then we can again look at the local
importances in that action model so here
we will get various features that say
that for this particular lead the
features that were most important were
did this lead receive a discount offer
in the past six months and then the next
most important feature might
how many times in this li get reached
out to buy a salesperson in the past
year so by looking at the local
importances who are able to see what
actually are the features so what are
the actions that a salesperson could
take that would be most explainable in
the model to try to drive a sales
forward so the point of this is that we
can address business needs with standard
tools just used in novel ways so in this
particular example I use it a couple of
different tricks the models were stacked
where each layer in the stack had
different explanatory variables where
the first layer was characteristics of
the actual customers that we're trying
to make predictions for and the second
player was features which are based on
interactions between that lead and the
sales team so by having these different
layers of models which have very
different features were able to pin
point out the different reasons why a
salesperson might want to reach out and
then also what actions should be taken
so also I add feature later in the model
were leveraging the individual model
types to achieve the business goals so
two of the business goals that we were
initially given involved maybe some
something explainable we need to be able
to tell a client lie about something so
because random forests have this nice
local importances built into them then
you can use that to answer those
questions so a couple things to be
careful of when you're doing something
also like this I just building any stack
model instead of using some
just off the shelf I you need to be
extra careful to avoid some pitfalls so
in one example is information leakage in
this case because all of the features in
that first model where characteristics
of the leads themselves that is not
going to be very problematic in having
this two layer ensemble in that second
layer you can imagine that some fun some
salespeople would be more likely to
reach out to very large institutions so
reach out to for example a Stanford
biology department as opposed to
focusing on the ones that we've up that
we thought were most relevant it looks
like a tactile thanks another issue is
outlier effects so if you have a first
layer in your model which is very bad at
extrapolation and you need to make
extrapolations then having that feed
into a second model is going to cause
problems again by having these two
layers you need to worry about
bias-variance tradeoff not only in the
whole ensemble but at each layer so I
there are I'm sure a slew of other
things that you need to be very careful
about when you're building your own like
this but I think that this is something
that I just as a example in this fog has
been working through starting with
business requirements and then actually
building a model that addresses them one
by one like this so I hope that you were
able to get something out of that and I
am open to questions
[Applause]
I'll start it off did you
I didn't hear the word causality I don't
think but it seems like you're thinking
a lot about causal issues do you is
there any path forward these things to
sort of introduce counterfactual
reasoning or causal interventions like
that for example so for a relatively
short time I am glossing over plenty of
the details as you can imagine the we
don't need to address causality directly
for this particular use phase because
from these requirements we just need to
like understand the leads work in the
context of the salespersons
company so there's no causality that is
required there we just need to have a
case so that when a salesperson picks up
the phone to call someone they know
instantly what type of person they're
talking to and similarly in what types
of actions to take we do not mean to
have I saw you here that would be very
very nice if we did have that but again
we are just making recommendations these
when we have a so any company that has a
sales team is almost by definition
selling something expensive otherwise it
would just all be done through marketing
because of that we are going to rely
very heavily on the sales team to make
good decisions so we are providing
recommendations about the actions to
take by giving them the additional
context of why not it is relevant to
their company we expect them to be able
to understand what are the rules for my
company and are they do they feel
empowered to give them a discount maybe
not if it is a new prospect someone
that's not already a current customer
whereas they might be willing to take
some actions but
get on the phone more often because then
that's something that doesn't cost the
company I said two questions can you
tell us or talk to us about how you're
capturing the interactions between the
salespeople and the customers and then
also can you talk to us about the
journey of getting adoption themselves
as sounds people mm-hm so the
salesperson activity so our product
integrates with Salesforce so our client
our clients will connect Salesforce to
our app and then we pull in all of that
information we also allow clients to
integrate their exchange or gmail email
services so that we can see email
exchanges over time between the client
and customers and that also includes
calendar if that comes through exchange
or through Google so we can see when
that actually should blend meetings
actually took place on the user at the
client's company and when it took place
on their calendar so this is all being
pulled in without the client company
doing anything to provide that except to
expose the Salesforce API and then about
your second question
try the adoption we have had as you
might expect different levels of
eagerness to adopt our product new
salespeople are absolutely thrilled
about what we're providing because it
gives them a way to get jump-started
immediately and start performing at the
same level as people who have well
established entrenched networks and for
people that have those deep networks
already we're giving them an opportunity
to understand where they could be
spending the time most effectively so
it's different levels of adoption
primarily based on salesperson
experience
you